these are photographs of doctors who've
died of covet 19.
a memorial outside peru's medical
college in lima
honors more than 260 doctors who've died
from the virus
[Music]
it's led to a strike with medics calling
on the government for better working
conditions
and supplies without them they fear more
doctors and patients
will die
23 of my doctors have died 80 percent of
them were specialists
both young and old have passed away my
hospital is difficult to reach
you can only get there by plane or boat
if i need oxygen
it won't arrive in time
countries in central and south america
are tackling a second wave of the virus
but the first one never ended a new
strain of the virus has been detected in
the brazilian state of amazonas
and now colombia has announced flight
restrictions
for a period of 30 days passenger
flights from colombia to brazil and from
brazil to colombia will be suspended
more than 220 000 brazilians have died
of covet 19.
in this hospital in the city of manaus
medical staff are
already tackling the new variant
scientists believe
it's powering an increase in new
infections by up to 40 percent
nearly three-quarters of all icu beds
in many brazilian states from the
northern
regions of the amazon to the southern
border of uruguay
are being used to treat cova patients
in parts of guatemala medical staff
stepped out of hospitals to set up
testing
centers in popular markets out of 250
cova tests
an average of 40 people test positive
every day
the situation seems a bit careless i
think the measures in place aren't
strong enough
the government needs to be more strict
about it
but in a continent where much of the
economy depends on mobility
and street vendors many fear things will
get worse
before they get better katya lopez
al jazeera